Bitte schön.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, geben Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach.
Wie heißen Sie?
Nicole Müller.
Nicole mit C?
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Herr Müller.
Nee, Frau Müller, 50 Jahre alt.
Verraten Sie mir, wie viel Ihr Geburtstatus?
Erster 1972.
Wie groß sind Sie?
71.
Wie viel wiegeln Sie?
82.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Müller?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe einen Kind, ja.
Ja, Frau Müller, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe seit drei Tagen Luftnot.
Luftnot?
Okay.
Okay, können Sie mir bitte genau beschreiben,
wann haben Sie Luftnot bei Belastung oder in Ruhe?
Wie treten diese Beschwerden auch?
Ich habe Beschwerden auch in Ruhe.
Okay.
Das reicht auch beim Belastung.
Genau.
Also ich kann mich nicht mehr belassen, weil ich so viel Luftnot habe.
Okay.
Und können Sie flach liegen?
Nein, wo bin ich dann, kann ich nicht flach liegen.
Okay.
Dann zum Schlafen benutzen Sie ein paar Kisten, ja?
Ja, ich versuche höher zu schlafen.
Okay.
Wie viel Kisten benutzen Sie?
Ich habe meinen eigenen Kisten, aber ich versuche mich,
so sitzend hinzulegen.
Okay.
Haben Sie enge Gefühle oder Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen, nein.
Aber ich kriege nicht so gut Luft,
denn ich ist ein bisschen eng in der Brust, ja.
Wie waren Sie vorher, vor drei Tagen,
wie sind diese Beschwerden aufgetreten?
Vor drei Tagen?
Ja, er hört nicht oder langsam,
oder im Laufe der Zeit sind die Beschwerden...
Na ja, es ist halt seit drei Tagen, das weiß ich nicht.
Das ist halt seit drei Tagen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das vorher war.
Also vorher ging es mir eigentlich gut.
Okay.
Vorher konnten Sie Sport treiben?
Ich bin nicht so sportlich.
Haben Sie erbrochen oder ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, ich habe keine Übelkeit.
Ich habe nur Luftnot und so enge Gefühlinge der Brust.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich wieblich?
Wie?
Ziebrig?
Ja.
Nein.
Okay.
Sonst haben Sie noch irgendwelche Beschwerden?
Herzrasen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass mein Herz schneller schlägt.
Wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Immer oder sind Sie wieder weg?
Seit drei Tagen.
Immer haben Sie Herzrasen.
Nicht immer, aber mal mehr, mal weniger.
Aber ich habe Herzrasen jetzt.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob diese Beschwerden etwas verstärkt?
Gibt es etwas, was diese Beschwerden verstärkt oder blindert?
Nein.
Okay.
Was haben Sie beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich die Tage etwas mehr Wasser lassen muss.
Aber mit dem Stuhlgang habe ich keine Probleme.
Seit drei Tagen.
Ja.
Trinken Sie genug Wasser?
Wie viel trinken Sie?
Ich trinke einen Liter am Tag.
Nein.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Seit drei Tagen.
Sie meinen Wasserlassen?
Genau.
Oft.
Ich habe mich gezählt.
Ich muss nachts sehr oft raus.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorerkrankungen ein paar Fragen stellen.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich nehme Medikamente zur Blutverdünnung.
Der Arzt hat vor vier Jahren gesagt, dass etwas am Rhythmus nicht stimmt.
Dann ist das wieder normal geworden.
Aber ich muss die Blutverdünnung einnehmen.
Ich habe Bluthochdruck.
Dann nehme ich auch zwei Tabletten ein.
Ich habe aber nicht.
Die Blutverdünnungstablette kenne ich auch nicht.
Ich kann mir das alles nicht merken.
Ich habe meinen Medikamentenplan zu Hause vergessen.
Ich war damals vor vier Jahren beim Kardiologen.
Ich bin sehr verletzt.
Wir müssen eine Reaktion haben.
Die Patient hat einen Entgegiffel.
Er hat sehr viel Luft.
Ryu Baynare hat sehr viel Luft.
Ich habe pedalspurgeln.
Ich habe his anderen Räume.
Ich habe Schw grade Figures.
next class
Ich habe eine Schwede.
Was soll die Reaktion sein?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wir, diese Situation, welche Reaktion...
Ach, was muss der Arzt machen, wenn ich sage, dass ich Luftnot habe und dass es mir nicht gut geht?
Wenn ich in einen Sauerstoff gebe?
Ja genau, das ist sehr gut. Das muss man eigentlich immer sagen, dann freut sich der Prüfer.
Also wenn Sie jetzt Luftnot haben, kriegen Sie jetzt erstmal Sauerstoff von mir.
Wir schreiben mal sofort ein EKG und machen Sie mal an den Monitor dran.
Das sage ich ja immer, ich sage das ja jedes Mal. Jetzt habe ich es vergessen.
Also ist es gut, wenn der Arzt sagt, dass der Patient tatsächlich kein richtiger Notfall,
weil der Patient hat das seit drei Tagen, ist ja kein akute Luftnot.
Aber trotzdem, wenn einer mit Luftnot kommt, sehr gut, dann muss man sagen,
wir machen Sauerstoff dran, hier hängen Sie an dem Monitor dran, überwachen den Rhythmus
und schreiben mal ein EKG. Und dann kann man weiter machen. Stimmt.
Genau.
Prüfer, ja.
Okay.
Haben wir das gemacht?
Also ich war vor vier Jahren, haben wir gemacht jetzt, genau.
Ich war vor vier Jahren beim Kardiologen und der hat damals gesagt,
dass eine Klappe nicht so gut ist. Ich weiß aber nicht, welche Klappe.
Die Klappe ist verkeilt, hat er mir gesagt.
Verkeilt.
Okay.
Sonst habe ich, weiß ich, sonst habe ich eigentlich keine Erkrankungen.
Okay, Sie sind schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte einen Kaiserschnitt, als ich mein Kind auf die Welt gebracht habe.
Ich bin in Ihrer Familie, wesentliche Erkrankungen,
um denen ich wissen sollte, wie ein Blutzucker oder Herzkrankheiten Krebs.
Ja, meine Mutter hatte Krebs.
Was für Krebs?
Mir ein Zellkarzinom.
Mein Vater ist Gott sei Dank gesund.
Ja, sonst eigentlich nichts.
Aber Herr Dorf, da das mit der Luft wird das besser?
Warum kriege ich keine Luft?
Ich habe Angst, weil ich Luftnot habe.
Können Sie mir da helfen, wird das besser mit meiner Luft?
Okay, Sauerstoff hat Ihnen nicht geholfen.
Ja, aber ich will, es ist besser geworden.
Aber ich will wissen, woher das kommt.
Warum habe ich Luftnot?
Ja, Sie haben nicht alle Untersuchungen durchgeführt,
aber beim EKG haben Sie ein Herzrasen und Stabilis.
Stabilis, Angina pectoris habe ich nicht.
Was ist Angina pectoris?
Angina pectoris ist eng gefühlt.
Was ist Angina?
Angina heißt Schmerz.
Pektoris heißt Brust.
Angina pectoris heißt Brustschmerz.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen angegeben.
Ich habe keine Angina pectoris.
Entschuldigung, ich habe etwas vergessen.
Ich habe vergessen, Ihnen zu sagen,
dass ich Insulin spritze.
Ich habe Diabetes.
Ich habe vergessen, dass ich immer zu sagen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Wenn Sie etwas Akutes haben, können wir die Weitstellung
untersuchen und direkt machen.
Aber es wäre super, super, super, super, super.
Wenn wir das Gespräch am Ende zu führen.
Ja, okay.
Aber ich habe Angst, Herr Doktor.
Was habe ich denn?
Ja, leider kann ich Ihnen nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Erst mal, ich muss die Weitstellung untersuchen und durchführen.
Dann kann ich Ihnen sagen, welches...
Also gut, dann warte ich noch.
Also gut.
Okay.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig zum Blauen Arzt?
Das ist schon lange her.
Meine Gebärmutter ist schon draußen.
Warum?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Da ist etwas gewesen und dann haben Sie mir empfohlen,
dass die Gebärmutter raus muss.
Es war aber kein Krebs.
Okay.
Das war etwas Gutartiges.
Ich hatte so starke Blutung, deswegen musste die Gebärmutter raus.
Ich habe keine Gebärmutter.
Wann war das, genau?
Cool, das war vor 10 Jahren ungefähr.
Wann war der letzte Frauenarzt?
Kontroll.
Danach?
Ja.
Danach bin ich meine letzte.
Die ist auch schon zwei Jahre her.
War alles in Ordnung?
Ja, da war alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Jetzt habe ich Luft.
Jetzt habe ich gar keinen Appetit.
Aber eigentlich war mein Appetit gut.
Okay.
Wir haben wie mit Kamenze gesagt,
wir haben eine Blutverdünne
und zwei Bluthochdruckverblicken gegen Bluthochdruck.
Sonst nehmen Sie irgendwelche
Aussage noch ins Bild.
Ich habe früher geraucht.
Ich habe 20 Jahre lang geraucht.
Aber ich habe vor 20 Jahren aufgehört.
15 Jahren aufgehört.
Entschuldigung, sonst geht das nicht.
Wie viele Treten?
Was haben Sie geraucht?
Eine Packung am Tag, 20 Jahre lang.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Drogen?
Genau.
Wie kommen Sie darauf, dass ich Drogen einnehme?
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nein, ich nehme keine Drogen ein.
Ist Ihnen eine Allergie bekannt?
Nein, keine Allergie.
Meine Seite, Frau Munde, habe ich die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Müssten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie Fragen?
Jetzt, wie ich Ihnen gesagt habe,
erst mal ich würde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach würde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen
und ein Herz-Ultraschall durchführen.
Ich würde Ihnen eine Begründung geben.
Ein Herz-Ultraschall durchführen.
Je nachdem, wie die Ergebnisse besprechen,
besprechen wir noch mal.
Alles klar.
Ich sehe es nicht.
Haben Sie Husten?
Husten?
Nein, so ein Reizhusten.
Ich kratze am Halb.
Aber kein Husten richtig.
Haben Sie Durstgefühl?
Nein.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Beine.
Die Knöchel sind dick, ja.
Beide Knöchel sind dick.
Seit wann?
Beine.
Ich weiß nicht,
ich habe schon länger, dass sie dicker sind.
Wissen Sie, morgen sind wir wieder schlanker.
Dann bin ich aufstehen und laufe abends.
Wenn ich dann sitze, sind die dick.
Noch ein Problem.
Ich möchte gerne Ihre Medikamente erzielen.
Aber das fragen Sie sowieso.
Mein Hausarzt.
Mein Hausarzt ist Dr. Schmidt.
Jetzt soll ich die Patientenvorstellung anfangen.
Patientenvorstellung soll ich anfangen.
Wenn Sie alles gefragt haben.
Meine Leitschaft habe ich alles gefragt.
Aber ich brauche eine Minute bitte.
Ja gerne, kein Problem.
Ich kann noch 2 Minuten haben.
Sind Sie vonständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Also 2 Mal geimpft und einmal geboostert.
Was sind Sie von bernof?
Ich bin Hausfrau.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wichtig ist.
Meine 3. Impfung hatte ich Anfang Februar.
Seit der Impfung war es mir so schlecht.
Ich wurde immer schlechter.
Was war die letzte Impfung?
Meine Impfung war vor 14 Tagen.
Nach der Impfung ging es mir eine Woche nicht so gut.
Ich war schlapp.
Ich habe ein Bett gelegen.
Danach habe ich mich nicht so richtig erholt.
Jetzt habe ich die 3 Tage Druck auf der Brust.
Diese Luftnot immer mehr.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Zum Beispiel Blutlof.
Ich habe die letzte Impfung zurückgeführt.
Es ist mir jetzt erst eingefallen.
Ich habe jetzt erst gemerkt.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit?
Zeit, nicht Zeit.
Zeit.
Was nochmal?
Ob ich in der letzten Zeit pass?
Nein, ich habe die Zeit.
Ich habe nicht eingefallen.
Was nochmal?
Nein, ich habe die Zeit.
Ich habe jetzt über den Covid-19 geholt.
Ich habe nicht hier hin infragequehen.
Wenn ich nicht mehr fragte,
dann darauf habe ich eine Frage.
Ich möchte ihnen eine Patrimonietin vorstellen.
Vorstellen haben Sie kurz Zeit. Gerne. Es geht um Frau Nicole Uehler, sie ist 50 Jahre alt und
82 Kilo und 171 Zentimeter groß. Sie klappt über 1 Meter 72 groß, sagt man, nicht 172
Zentimeter, das sagt man auf gar keinen Fall. 1 Meter 72 Zentimeter, müssen Sie gar nicht sagen,
1 Meter 72 groß. 1 Meter 72 groß, genau. Sie klappt über Atemnot seit 3 Tagen nicht nur beim
Belastung, sondern auch in Ruhe und sie kann nicht, sie hat auch Otopne seit,
gleichzeitig und Tachikadi. Tachikadi auf Deutsch. Tachikadi ist rückisch. Tachikadi und diese,
und sie müssen, als weiterer Bechwerden nennt sie Nocturie seit 3 Tagen und Reizüsten und indem
im Beide, Beide. Egal, Knöchel oder Unterschenkel. Knöchel habe ich gesagt, aber man kann
doch sagen Unterschenkel. Im Beide Unterschenkel und sie hat, sie hat letzte Corona-Impfung,
dritte Corona-Impfung am Februar vor 30 Tagen bekommen. Vor 14 Tagen. Vor 14 Tagen, ja. Und
die Beschwerden sind nach der Impfung aufgetreten. So langsam aufgetreten, ja. Sie hat in Vorerkrankungen
liegt Arithmy seit 4 Jahren und arteriale Hypertonie vor. Ja, oder man kann auch sagen, an amnestisch
Vorhoflimmern, Arithmy, also, sie hat ja nicht gesagt, was es ist, aber wenn sie sagt, sie nimmt
Blutverdünnung ein, weil sie eine Rhythmusstörung hat, dann kann es ja nur Vorhoflimmern sein.
An amnestisch, wenn man sagt, an amnestisch Vorhoflimmern heißt das, man weiß es nicht genau, man hat es nicht
schwarz auf weiß gelesen irgendwo, sondern das ist nur das, was der Patient gesagt hat. Man kann
einfach sagen, an amnestisch liegt ein Vorhoflimmern vor mit Oraleantikogolation. Hat ja eine Oraleantikogolation,
nennt man ja so. An amnestisch Vorhoflimmern und arteriale Hypertonie vor, dagegen nimmt sie
Antikogolan mit und Bluthochdruckmedikamente. Oraleantikogolation, sie hat gesagt, sie nimmt
Tabletten ein für die Blutverdünnung. Das nennt man Oraleantikogolation. Genau.
Oraleantikogolation und Blutdruckmedikamente, Antihypertensiv. Antihypertensiv war.
Antihypertensiv war. Antihypertensiv war. Genau. Und sie hat auch erwähnt, dass sie vor vier
Jahren eine Wurde bei ihr eine klappe, eine Herzklappe Funktion Störung festgestellt. Sehr gut,
genau. Super, super, super Formuliert. Sehr gut, ja. Und sie hat auch Diabetes mellitus und
dagegen Spritze, wie Insulin. Oder sie hat Insulinpflichtigen Diabetes mellitus, kann
man auch sagen, man muss nicht sagen, da gehen Spritze Insulin, sondern man kann sagen, sie hat
einen Insulinpflichtigen Diabetes mellitus. Man hätte sie ja noch fragen können, wie
ein Lebensjahr sie den Diabetes entwickelt hat, ob das ein Typ 1, Typ 2 Diabetes ist,
das wissen die meisten Patienten. Bei Insulinpflichtigen Diabetes, wenn die 50 Jahre alt sind, frag
ich immer, ob das ein Typ 1 oder Typ 2 Diabetes ist. Ich hatte auch schon einen 60-Jährigen,
wo ich gedacht habe, das ist bestimmt ein Typ 2 Diabetes, aber der Patient hat selber Gott sei
Dank zu mir gesagt, dass das ein Typ 1 Diabetes ist. Das ist wichtig für die Therapie nachher,
weil Typ 1 Diabetes kann neigen ja zu Keto-Azidosen, die darf man halt nicht bei
Voruntersuchungen, muss man denen halt so ein bisschen Infusion geben, weil die ganz schnell
zu einer Keto-Azidose neigen. Also es ist schon wichtig zu wissen, ob das ein Typ 1 oder
Typ 2 Diabetes ist. Also vielleicht müssen Sie das in der Prüfung halt nur sagen dann.
Ja, ja. In der Familienanamnese liegt die Mutterlandscheid-Nieren-Zerkratinom vor und bei
ihr wurde Historectomy durchgeführt vor zehn Jahren wegen starker Blutung. Möglicherweise, was
ist es dann, wenn sie starke Blutung hatte, wenn das gemachte Myom wahrscheinlich,
eine Uterusmyomatosis oder so was. Ich habe ja gesagt, das war nichts Bösartiges. Egal, also es war
auf jeden Fall nichts Bösartiges, muss man dazu sagen. Es reicht, wenn man sagt, dass sie
hysterektomiert worden ist vor, keine Ahnung, was habe ich gesagt vor zehn Jahren, aber das
laut Patient war das nichts Bösartiges. Also so sagt ich das immer, wenn ich das vorstellen
möchte. Wie hat das vor zehn Jahren, 20 Jahre Einpackung Trarete geraucht? Man kann auch gleich
sagen 20 Päck hier ist Nikotinkonsum. Was ist das denn? So errechnet man das ja, ne? Ja, ja. Also
man kann auch gleich sagen 20 Päck hier ist Nikotinkonsum. War alles richtig, was sie
gesagt haben um Gott zu finden. Also es war Formulierung war auch alles richtig.
Okay, ja, sie sind zu Beschwerden. Und dann, wie ist der Namnese? Nach dem bisherigen Angaben,
gehe ich von New Califis aus, um meine Verdacht zu bestimmen, meine Verdacht zu bestätigen,
würde ich die Patienten erstmal körperlich untersuchen und Blut, ihr Blut abnehmen. Was nehmen
sie ab? Erstmal großes Flugbild und Entzündungparameter und Herzwerte. Bei welcher Herzwerte? Troponin.
Troponin und CK, CK-MB und? Enp, ne? Ja. Pro BNP, ist ganz richtig. Okay, ja, gut. Entzündungparameter.
Was würden wir bei dieser Patientin noch abnehmen, diese Frau, diese Frau, die Luftnot hat, was
müssen wir bei ihr noch abnehmen? Ja, Dedima. Dedima. Dedima, das ist ganz wichtig, sehr gut,
genau. Dedima, Troponin haben wir dann auch, dann haben wir diese eine Palette auch abgeklärt,
BNP, Troponin, Dedima, haben wir ja alles. Okay, Herz und Züme haben wir, okay. Was noch?
Luftnot, könnte Entzündung sein, Entzündungswerte haben wir auch, sehr gut. So, was könnte denn
die Diagnose sein? Die Diagnostik kommt. Sie können sagen, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist,
eine Myokaditis, weil die Patientin die Beschwerden nach der Impfung entwickelt hat, ne? Das ist so,
ne? Das denken Sie. Genau. Aber es könnte auch gut was sein. Die Franzialkiagnostik kommt zum Beispiel
uns stabil angina pectoris, uns stabil angina pectoris. Nein, akutes Coronasyndrom. Okay, akutes
Coronasyndrom. Wir sagen einfach jetzt akutes Coronasyndrom. Okay. Könnte ein akutes
Coronasyndrom sein? Warum könnte das ein akutes Coronasyndrom sein oder eine angina pectoris
kann es ja nicht sein? Sie hat ja keine Schmerzen. Ein akutes Coronasyndrom könnte es sein,
obwohl sie keine Schmerzen hat. Warum könnte bei dieser Patientin ein akutes Coronasyndrom
vorlegen, obwohl sie keine Brustschmerzen angibt? Doch das wissen Sie. Ich habe extra gesagt,
dass die Patientin Typ 1, Typ 2 Diabetikerin wichtig ist. Neuropathie wegen der Neuropathie. Nein,
wegen dem Diabetes. Sie müssen sagen, sehr gut. Diabetes, Diabetikerin. Patente,
Diabetikerin müssen Sie sagen, ja. Und jede Patientin, wirklich jede, die Diabetiker
sind und Luftnot haben. Wir haben ganz viele Patienten, die einfach nur etwas Beklemmungen
in der Brust haben, keine Schmerzen, ein bisschen Beklemmung und eigentlich nur Luftnot haben,
nur Luftnot. Und in Silindslichtigen Diabetes seit Jahren, die haben oftmals eine Herzinfarkt.
Man sieht es, man merkt es nicht. Deswegen immer sagen, bei den Patienten könnte
Auswärterin Jörg Caditis ein Akuts Coronasyndrom vorlegen. Warum? Weil die Patientin Diabetikerin
ist, muss die Kanäle beschwerden, die Schmerzen haben. Da geht es nur ein bisschen Druck noch.
Was könnte es noch sein? Die Prinzelldiagnose. Pulmonanemboli. Lungen, Arterienemboli.
Sagen Sie das? Lungen, Arterienemboli. Genau, sehr gut. Wir sagen, das ist so eine Lungen, Arterienemboli.
Warum? Was passt zu einer Lungen, Arterienemboli? Ich habe extra ein Fall genommen, was zu allem passt.
Was passt für eine Lungen, Arterienemboli? Dafür sprechen die Odemen am Beinen und
damit fangen wir nicht an. Was spricht für die Lungen, Arterienemboli? Was hat die Patientin für Beschwerden?
Weswegen kommt die? Enge Gefühl? Nein, Luftnot. Sie kommt mit Luftnot.
Was ist die Hauptleitbild einer Lungen, Arterienemboli ist Luftnot. Also sie hat Luftnot.
Was hat sie noch? Enge Gefühl? Passt auf, ne? Luftnot und Herzrasen. Herzrasen passt.
Warum passt das Herzrasen? Ja, sehr gut. Ja.
Rechts, Herz, Herz, Belastung. Rechts, Herz, Belastung. Als Rechts-Herts-Belastungszeichen haben die
Patienten hohes Troponin, hohes BNP, und was haben sie noch? Sie haben eine hohe Herzfrequenz
und was haben sie noch im EKG? Was gucken wir uns im EKG an? Jetzt machen wir später. Ist okay.
Herzrasen, das passt für Lungen, Arterienemboli. Vierte Differenzialdiagnose, das brauchen wir
jetzt aber auch noch. Oder die Dritte, wir sind bei der Dritten erst. Ja, vierte. Dritte.
Differenzialdiagnose, dritte Differenzialdiagnose. Okay. Was hat die Patientin extra gesagt?
Was hat sie? Sie hat vor vier Jahren. Vor vier Jahren, Klappe, Herzklappe, Herzweilwerk.
Welche Herzklappe bei älteren Leuten, wo sie es jetzt 50 Jahre alt, das passt nicht, ne?
Wenn es jetzt eine 80-jährige Oma wäre und sie hat sagt vor vier Jahren war die Klappe
verkalkt und sie ist 80 Jahre alt, dann ist es fast immer die Ortenklappenstinnose.
Und deswegen müssen sie bei diesen Patienten immer fragen, sind sie schon mal bewusstlos
geworden, haben sie Schwindel? Ja, das ist ganz oft. Luftnot, Druck auf der Brust, die
drei Seichen und Schwindel. Das ist Ortenklappenstinnose bei 80-Jährigen, aber diese ist erst 50,
ne? Das heißt, es kann eine Mitralklappeninsuffizient sein, es kann eine Mitralklappenstinnose sein,
es kann ja alles Mögliche sein, das wissen wir ja jetzt nicht. Aber die Klappe könnte die
Ursache sein, ne? Ja. Das finden wir woraus, wo sehen wir das ganz einfach, ob das die Klappe ist?
Das sehen wir ganz schnell. Schokadio-Presen. Sehr gut, genau, das machen wir ja auch noch. Super.
Genau. Und das andere ist, jetzt kommt, ja, jetzt kommt die vierte Diagnose. Was hat sie
gesagt? Sie nimmt Anticoagulation. Warum nimmt sie Anticoagulation? Vorvorfilme? Ja, und sie ist
Tachikat, haben wir gesagt. Sie hat Herzrasen. Was kann sie haben? Ganz einfach, haben die meisten
Patienten. Tachikadesvorhoflemann. Tachiarhythmia absoluta bei Vorhoflemann. Tachikadesvorhoflemann
kann sie haben. Genau. Und Tachikadesvorhoflemann führt nämlich auch ganz schnell dazu,
dass die Patienten KDLD kompensieren. Okay. Blut haben wir super, haben sie super gemacht,
die Lungenembolie ist abgedeckt mit D-Demmeretroponin und BMP. Und dann haben wir abgeklärt,
zick-zicker im Betroponin. Herzinfarkt, Akut-Kronasymprum. Und dann haben wir Infektparameter
Lungenentzündung, zum Beispiel die fünf-Veterinzialdiagnose, kann ja auch sein. Jetzt haben wir alles.
Ich habe extra so ein Fall genommen, weil das ist oft bei uns. Da muss man überlegen,
was hat der Patient? Ja. Jetzt haben wir gesagt, gucken wir uns das EKG an. Was sehen wir,
wenn es ein Lungenembolie ist? Ein Argmie? Nein. Was ist typisch für Lungenembolie?
Tachikadi, das haben Sie doch schon gesagt. Tachikad, sagen wir mal Tachikadi. Tachikadi.
Tachikadi. Was noch? Was haben die noch? Nur das müssen Sie wissen,
zwei Sachen. Rechtschenkelblock, Rechtsherzbelastung. Ja. Okay. Auch wenn Sie es nicht sehen,
Sie müssen sagen, ja. Also Rechtschenkelblock, Tachikadi, könnte schon mal ein Hinweis dafür sein,
wegen der Rechtsherzbelastung am Rechtsherzblock, rechtschenkelblock. Das ist ein Zeichen zum
Beispiel für die Lungenembolie. Und was können wir noch sehen? Die Tachiarotinia absoluta sehen
wir. Vorhoflemann, schnelles Vorhoflemann, Frequenz um die 120. Auch die Ursache könnte es sein.
Und was sehen wir beim Akuts-Kronasymprum oder beim Herzinfarkt? Entweder Hebungen,
dann ist es ein Erhöhunginfarkt oder Senkungen, dann ist es ein Entstehenakuts-Kronasymprum. Oder,
aber Sie sehen gar nichts. Und trotzdem ist es ein Akuts-Kronasymprum. Das sieht man dann nur im
Labor. Und bei der Ordentlichlappenstinnnose zum Beispiel sieht man über Truffib-Zeichen,
im EKG. Aber das müssen Sie alles nicht wissen. Alles gut, alles okay. Und dann machen wir
ein Echo. Als nächstes, wir haben schon so viel, schon erreicht. Wir können schon nachher aus
genau sagen, was der Patient hat. Und dann machen wir Echo und was sehen wir im Echo bei der
Lungenembolie? Lungenembolie legen wir wieder rechte Herzbelastung. Rechts Herz ist groß,
genau. Sehr gut. Punkt nicht zu gut. Das rechte Herz, das rechte Herz ist groß. Das Detail
müssten Sie nicht wissen. Bei der Herzensuffizienz, das haben wir gar nicht gesagt, das können
wir ja auch einfach eine Herzunzuffizienz haben, was der Patient hat. Als Differenzialdiagnose. Dann sehen
Sie einfach, dass das Herz nicht gut pumpt. Dann müssen wir herausfinden, warum. Genau. Bei der KKK,
das heißt Akuts-Kronasymprum, Jokatin-Fac, ist ja eine KKK, dann sehen wir, dass bestimmte
Abschnitte nicht gut pumpen. Das spricht dafür, dass keine Blutung nicht gut ist. Und was haben
wir noch gesagt? Herzunzuffizienz, Lungenembolie haben wir gesagt. Wir haben alles gesagt. Auf dem Klappe
können wir uns alles sehen. Klappe sehen wir halt. Klappen können wir uns auch angucken. Das war gut,
das war sehr gut. Deswegen, und aber jetzt haben Sie aber sich selber reingritten. Sie haben gesagt,
es könnte eine Myocarditis sein. Okay, reicht das alles, was wir gemacht haben für die Myocarditis?
Herzunzüme, okay, Sie sind erhöht. Das könnte ja auch eine Herzinfarkt sein, woher weiß ich
denn jetzt, dass das eine Myocarditis ist? Der Patient hat ein Hustroponin, normale CKCKNB,
das heißt auf jeden Fall Zeichnungs- und Akuts-Kronasymprum im Labor. Echokartigraphie ist
unauffällig. So, und woher weiß ich jetzt, muss ich jetzt Herzkartite haben machen, oder was
mache ich jetzt? Woher weiß ich denn jetzt, ob das ein Herzinfarkt oder eine Myocarditis ist?
Was mache ich jetzt als nächstes? Nein, wenn Sie sagen, dass es eine Myocarditis ist,
dann müssen Sie auch sagen, wie man die Diagnose stellt. Kardiormer-T. Myocarditis sieht man nur im
Kardiormer-T. Okay, und wie ist die Therapie von der Myocarditis? Sie haben das gesagt,
also müssen Sie auch sagen, was die Therapie ist. Also es ist eine symptomatische Therapie,
da gibt es keine Therapie. Symptomatische Therapie mit nicht-derodalen Antirheumatika,
körperliche Schonung, ja, für mind. vier bis sechs Wochen körperliche Schonung,
nicht-derodale Antirheumatika, ja, und gegebenenfalls eine M.R.T.-Kontrolle. Aber die Studien sagen,
dass Patienten die vaccine-bedingt, also impf-bedingt Myocarditiden entwickeln,
das sind alles milde Verläufe. Da ist eigentlich noch nie einer wirklich dran gestorben, ja. Die
Patienten, die impf-bedingt diese Myocarditiden entwickeln, die haben eigentlich immer einen
guten Verlauf. Wenn die Patienten vor der Booster-Impfung eine Myocarditis entwickeln,
da muss man halt gucken, wie akut das ist, wie hoch die Enzyme sind, wie ausgeprägt der
Befund im Kardiormer-T ist. Danach muss man halt nur entscheiden, dass es wichtig nach der
zweiten Impfung, ob man boostert oder nicht. Dann darf man nicht boostern, ne, weil dann ist
es gefährlich. Aber ansonsten, super, sehr gut. Wir haben ganz viele Differenzialdiagnosen,
5, 6 Differenzialdiagnosen. Ja. Wann war, wann war? Ach so ein Röntgen würde ich auch machen, ne?
Ein Röntgen würde ich auch machen. Ja, für die Lungenembolie. Nee. Wo sehen Sie die Lungenembolie?
Nicht im Röntgen-Torax. Wo sehen Sie die Lungenembolie? Nicht im Röntgen-Torax. Im Röntgen-Torax,
den bitte im CT. Wenn Sie den Verdacht haben, wenn die Dämere erhöht ist, muss der Patient,
wenn die Dämere erhöht ist, auch eine Rechtsärztesbelastung im ECHO haben, wenn er eine Lungenembolie hat?
Nein. Nein. Junge Patienten haben immer so eine gute Funktion. Das Herz ist so gesund,
dass wenn die eine Lungenembolie haben, dass die keine Rechtsärztesbelastung zeigen. Aber die
haben eine akute Lungenembolie im CT. Oft ist es so, dass sie keine Rechtsärztesbelastungszeichen
haben. Muss nicht. CT, Röntgen machen wir nur um zu gucken, ob der eine Pneumonie hat oder ob der Wasser in der Lunge hat.
Okay, ja. Okay, das war gut. Also das Deutsche hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Die Aussprache ist super.
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass wir stehen. Alles super. Sehr gut. Ich hoffe, ich werde